that's a throwback yeah to
to their match in 2018 of course anyway
a little bit surprising but
uh
an interesting choice by sort of both of
them because magnus
uh
who we assume since we haven't really
heard anything uh to the opposite we
assume he gets a win in the last round
rosalina itself is also
uh potentially quite quite unbalanced
like a6 bishops yeah it went up
yeah bishop city
chess or maybe bishop a4 yeah
yeah it was this stuff and
a7 bishop d6 but should be seven and so
on but this time around carson plays
knight to f6 which
used to be the absolute main line in
particular these ideas would take some
bishop e3 or directly bishop v3
uh driving me slightly mental but i
don't know
knight goes somewhere c3 d2 i don't know
choose a
square
and black will get some pawns for the
piece but you normally don't fully
equalize in positions like this unless
you have an attack on the king side take
on c6 and say that
we're
not that unhappy but yeah which pay for
was always right
was always a favorite there uh rook c8
knight c3 in the meantime is on the
board in the magnus game
28 with the uh sort of a dual intention
of i mean currently knight takes e5 is
back
on the menu as a threat and bishop b3
has got knight a5 which i
i mentioned but i wasn't in love with
this because i couldn't really uh maybe
bishop ah
clever
i think his idea is to play bishop d5b5
and
get this bishop to trade for a knight
are we not worried about c4 at all or b5
yeah but then i think white is c4 white
is quite happily playing before and
saying
thou shall not pass take and go queen d2
and then
i keep on blundering bishop g4 though
okay bobby yeah magnus still thinking
and magnus did not go for
our a5 b5 plan
a5
but now you don't get a passport magnus
i guess he might want to play for anyone
q and a6 and then maybe a4 or b5 a4 i
think the major point was that by by
playing b6 he uh as we see from from
fabi's reaction he lured the queen away
from the king side so he is
uh very much shifting the
the
focal point of the game towards
center queenside and so on so he no
longer really has to worry about getting
mated
i'm not sure what the counter play is
yeah i was going to say
you know create create something of our
own but i don't know what the
probably is some some kind of queen h6
and b5 and then something on the queen
side it's very slow
rook c6
would be interesting but the other rook
is now kind of tied to the protection of
the e7 pawn
yeah and also white could try being
concrete and c3 c4 is very much in that
spirit
magnus what should magnus do yeah i'm
protect the ball on d5 probably i'm
just wondering how exactly bishop c6
maybe two
magnus has gone for
the line you mentioned with
over the board but
i just like it it would it would seem
extremely weird to just sort of let him
back in
yeah magnus's game actually underwent a
lot of changes because five chose to
hard stop the b7b5 at the cost of
providing black with this really really
beautiful bishop on c6
uh and now there is a
not insignificant passer on a4 which
white cannot really attack all that easy
easily
finally played rook fc one this looks
like a decisive result is still in the
car so i saw the engine like white
earlier
now it's
shifting its elite it's shifting and
also this is just a very tricky position
to play for i think both blender
i'm still not sure like i've bishop
takes f3 in general is probably not a
great move
so
i don't know rook a8 just on he went
rook cd8 instead
feels like he
yeah i'm not sure what the rook is doing
on d8 just sort of for future reference
putting it on a
on a good square i felt like putting it
behind the pass pawn can not really be a
mistake but
with the knight vacating the f3 square
queen e2 becomes
more of an option i don't know if it's a
good move but you can definitely
consider playing it trying to get it to
g4 faster
okay so he did play f3 and apparently
rook takes d4 here is very strong but
yeah i considered it but it's not
obvious that it's so strong yeah i mean
it's very playable the bishop sticks now
is completely unchallengeable this is
very much
trouble for white now i don't even know
if you're supposed to like i don't think
black is forced to take 25 at least not
straight away i think there's definitely
an argument to be made to be for playing
rook d8 first
oh the pawn e5 appears to be a goner and
with two for the exchange and the bishop
on six being such a monster it's just
not going to be fun for fabi to defend
yeah in particular in particular if the
hang on a second what
it's not the queen trade that the engine
hates i'm pretty sure because the queen
trade keeps the pawn only five alive
but queen e3 bishop v5 we can do no
yeah
we could have yeah we could have done
this uh at any point and yeah
interestingly i was i was sort of
advocating for the move h7 h5 instead of
e6 but magnus also went for kind of a
slow move
not committing to any structure changes
yet
yeah i don't know like machines
generally yeah and he whoa magnus is
wellness is on point today
this is quite impressive levels of
correct assessment because i'd be very
worried about trading queens in a way
that doesn't win the e5 pawn
and i will see if five also agrees with
how annoying bishop is there
the full-blooded
full-blooded fight today just got out
played somewhere along the line
in the lineup i was wondering if magnus
changed his openings to make sure he
gets a fight but you don't need to
tricky discussion and fabia has realized
what before does it works he goes bishop
takes she takes e5 yeah opponent up in
the air and all that yeah you just
no you could have the debate for guys
like fabi maybe if they
let's say fabi wants to play the catalan
in the candidates and they're making up
openings and the the names of whatever
is
recovered for
or today
only fabiancy
but he's rich in bishops he's very rich
in bishops and yeah
you he he will he will now set up a
like he had a
beginnings of a kind of a
passive bathtub but the bathtub will i'm
actually surprised he hasn't played h5
yet i think he very much yeah and and
obviously five yeah is very much against
the idea of setting up the bathtub and
goes f3 f4 to be able to challenge it
but
should be easy enough to defend against
right you always kind of keep in mind
that this exists and keep rookie seven
in reserve he goes e5 very directly
he wants he wants the king on e7 and
sorry on f7 and e6 and
more diagonals for the bishops yeah
and yeah what you're saying about e5 i
absolutely agree with i would probably
start with king of seven at least to
have king e6 already in this position
for instance
but magnus is not not bothered in the
slightest declining to participate in it
so far but who knows what the future
holds
rook of eight king one plate
rook f5
obvious one probably being rook f4 g5
king of seven and preserving the pawn on
a4 just yeah black is just so so winning
here
more active pieces extra outside passer
nothing nothing really to discuss even
good moves in as much as you can make
them you just
if he's in the mood to lose on time that
particular day he will just lose on time
regardless of what you do
he has done that once or twice in his
career but
i think we we're actually sort of
watching the
the last throws here because bishop
check is a very clever idea i've been
uh expecting this to happen provoking g3
is hugely beneficial for black because
rook of three becomes
an option it probably is a very strong
option even immediately gh rook takes a3
looks
kind of bad but you could also just play
bishop g5 here for instance
and play it later like rook c3 bishop f6
the rook cannot really stay on the third
and then rook of three lands
and game kind of starts looking even
more lost than it is already
um
yeah expecting magnus to win this very
very comfortably
yeah if he goes rugby one but yeah
you kind of you kind of know how this
movie ends i guess he wants rook of
three bishop c1 maybe but then the yeah
fabi fabi is just so resilient
until today
yeah kudos to magnus play the fighting
opening was i don't know maybe slightly
worse out of the opening but it was
always unbalanced
and yeah just played better which
chad is saying farming is not doing well
because rostov is not with him
since magnus is winning all by himself
there will be no tie breaks right um
but ph never never really shirks from
asking the important questions
whether the parents say
yeah whether they're relevant for the
tournament situation or anything at all
or not it's just important questions
need to be asked yeah
always very pleasing to see him play
well because he continues playing
basically the same chess that he was
playing
when i started playing against him like
in the mid 90s obviously an extremely
strong player but he wasn't really
playing
cycle events anymore
yeah fabi did not resign but
not not save the game yeah just start
bringing the king in
a somewhat serious question
i don't know what your answer is he
finally has played king of seven
gotta try
rook f2
has been played
yeah
what are you doing all passers by
playing rook f3 here apparently
that's not even required but it sounds
like a move that wins on
on the spot
i already wore does it
not anymore yeah but i really really
like how you know it just goes wall to
wall one of my children suddenly
realized that he can use chess
because he needed physical education
marks
to to
to progress
and apparently chess counts as physical
education so he suddenly started taking
chess lessons
in uni just to get just to get great
sweaty
so you prefer peter batman or spiderman
we're having a debate magnus won
a
dominant display
by the world champion great judgment
great technique